it could be a blockbuster week of
testimony this week in the impeachment
hearings eight witnesses are expected to
speak publicly from tomorrow through
Thursday the witness list tomorrow
includes former Ukraine envoy kurt
volker and three people who heard
firsthand the July 25th phone call that
led to the impeachment inquiry Nancy
Cordes is on Capitol Hill with the new
developments Oh Nancy good morning
what's the latest good morning well we
learned a lot of new information over
the weekend including from two White
House advisors who described their
distress when the president pushed his
Ukrainian counterpart to investigate Joe
Biden all of this comes as the man who
was emerging as the real linchpin in
this case Gordon Sandlin is set to
testify this week I think Cruz has had a
good week Democrats are predicting
another good week in Washington as
Republicans downplay the evidence
gathered so far shouldn't it be based on
something that actually happened versus
one person's opinion of a third hand
conversation but in testimony Friday
diplomatic aide David Holmes told
lawmakers he was with US ambassador to
the EU
Gordon Sandland when Sunland called the
president home says he could hear
President Trump say so he's going to do
the investigation ambassador Sandlin
replied that the Ukrainian president
would do anything you asked him to
Holmes said Sandlin added that mr. Trump
only cares about big stuff that benefits
the president like the Biden
investigation that mr. Giuliani was
pushing the president had no interest in
the defense of the Ukraine he had one
thing in mind he wanted to shake down
President zalenski over the weekend
White House budget officials mark sandy
reportedly told lawmakers in private
testimony that the president's decision
to freeze aid to Ukraine this summer was
highly irregular and that he could never
get an explanation for it
Wisconsin Republican Ron Johnson argued
it would have been better if none of
this exposed that funding would have
been restored and our relationship with
Ukraine would be far better off than it
is today House Speaker Nancy Pelosi said
there's one witness who could clear
things up
the president could come back before the
committee and talk speak all the truth
that he wants if he wants to respect it
if he wants to take the oath of office
or he could do it in writing he has
every opportunity to present his case
this morning the president tweeted a
response to speaker Pelosi's request for
written testimony he says quote I like
the idea and will in order to get
Congress focused again strongly
considerate though there's no indication
when he might submit those answers week
ahead Nancy thank you very much and on
that big week CBS News will bring you
complete coverage of all the public
testimony in the impeachment inquiry
Norah O'Donnell will anchor our special
reports from Washington that's tomorrow
Wednesday and Thursday